- I remember picking them up in Columbus.
That's where we signed the contract.
I can't remember if I'm driving or if I'm in the back.
I'm counting the money.
- [Laughing]
- Whatchu counting like 10 racks right there in your hand or...
- Yeah, it was all hundreds. People start thinking, "Well, $500 a month.
I'm a freshman. I'm gonna have this for three years."
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- [Master Tesfatsion:] So, who we got in the pool hall today?
Oh we got a Hall of Famer, my man Cris Carter.
- [Cris Carter:] What's up, baby?
- How you living, brother?
- How you doing, man?
- Nice at a lot of things. Let's see how nice you are at pool.
- My hands is nice. They just ain't nice at pool.
- [Laughing]
- Come on. I’m all heart, man.
- You know a little bit about pool though.
- Oh! Come on, get in there!
- Solid break, solid break.
So, when did you start playing football?
- I started playing football at eight years old.
- Eight years old?
- I tried to play when I was seven. Me and my cousin went down to the park
and he was like, "Man, I'll doctor up the birth
certificate to make you born a year earlier."
I was trying to play when I was seven. And the lady was like,
"I think you need to bring your mom back."
I was like, "OK. I'll go home and get her."
A year later we didn't come back till.
- [Laughing]
- So yeah. That's my first experience with football was eight years old.
First time I touched a ball in a game, I scored a touchdown.
- At that point, it was just- it was history.
OK. So, young kid, Middletown, Ohio. What gravitates you to football?
- I loved the contact, man. I grew up a better basketball player
in high school until I turned 16, 17. Then, my
recruitment, I was All American in both,
but I was first team All American in football.
So in the process of trying to decide where I was gonna go to school,
I was only going to be recruited by schools who would let me play both.
So that's one of the reasons why I chose Ohio State.
- [Balls hitting. Ball dropping in socket.]
- OK. I’m so glad man we didn’t play for any money.
- [Laughing]
- OK!
- You get to Ohio State. What was that experience like and
what was going on in the background?
- That beginning was just not real good. And talking to my buddies,
they were talking about quitting and going back home.
And I was like, "Man, I can't go back to the crib."
- Like, "I can't go back."
- Why? Why was that not an option?
- When you grow up in a small town,
man, regardless of how good you are,
there are people that are always
trying to hold you back or say things.
- Mhmm.
- "You ain't gonna never make it. You ain't gonna be nothing."
But, man, you get those voices, man. Everyone gets them.
- For sure. What was it like for you in the
'80s, dealing with these ramifications
and these different stipulations of a different time?
- Well, it was totally against the rules, any type
of benefit for any type of student athlete.
So you didn't have the ability to work. You also didn't have the ability
to be able to take any type of endorsements or anything like that.
It was totally different. Today’s athletes-
- You said in air quotes. You couldn't take anything but
was the thing still going on behind the scenes?
- Absolutely. I made up my mind. I really wanted it.
I made the commitment, told them I wasn't gonna play basketball.
And then, the next month, the coach called me into his office and said,
"I gotta, uh, tell you something." I was like, "What is it?" He said,
"You've been one of the few freshmen in
the history of the Playboy All American,
that they're naming you to next year's Playboy All American team."
I was like, "Really?" And he was like, “Yeah.” I was like, “What does it require?”
And he said, “Well, they have a big photo shoot. It's gonna be in Miami.
We're gonna send someone down there with you."
- Ah, hell.
- First trip to Miami. This is before
your day, but man, Miami Vice was hot.
All right? Crockett, Tubbs. Bruh, they was it.
And then they told us we were staying at the hotel
where they were doing a lot of the filming and everything.
- Wow.
- Oh my goodness. So, we go to the photo shoot, and then,
some of the older guys, they're gonna take me
under their wing. They introduce me to a guy.
They say, "Man, I wanna introduce you to my guy."
That happened to be Lloyd Bloom, of
the legendary Lloyd and Norby Walters.
They were kind of booking agents in the music industry
and they had 10 of the top 15 Black artists in R&B
and they were trying to make a mark in sports.
- Wow.
- It was like, "Wow, this could be good."
They was talking about marketing the players with the bands,
going to see all these acts. And I was like,
"If I could just go to all these concerts, I'm
gonna be cool, if I don't do nothing else."
And I really thought, at that time, I was
doing something cutting edge, ahead of.
Like, I knew this was a decision I was gonna have three years from now,
but if I could take care of this now, and the
benefit of that, I think they gave me $15,000.
- 15 racks?
- Yeah. I remember picking them up in Columbus.
That's where we signed the contract, like that next week.
I can't remember if I'm driving or if I'm
in the back. I'm counting the money.
- [Laughing]
- It was all 100s. It was all 100s.
So I think I got 10 to sign, five
later on, and then also I got a car,
and then I got $500 a month that they Western Unioned.
You know, people start thinking, "Well, $500 a month.
I'm a freshman. I'm gonna have this for three years.”
- Wow.
- So I didn't have to worry about all that.
Immediately, they gave me an application for an American Express.
I was like, "I ain't never even had a credit
card." I ain't even ever lived in a house.
Man, I always lived in a housing project.
That was a good conversation.
-  You good. Oh, we just getting started, bro.
Oo, you sure you ain’t play before?
-  I didn't say I didn't play before. I just said I'm not that good at it.
- No that was sweet. That was nice.
If the NIL rules existed today when you were playing in college,
how much money you think you would've made?
-  It's not a- How much trouble you think I'm gonna get into?
- So what, what did money do for you then?
- The things I was doing, it just allowed me to do more of it.
And we were just smoking weed, just a little bit.
And that's just when cocaine, people
started smoking it, um, rocking it up.
And people had just started putting it in marijuana.
And, a guy at a party, man had put one in a
cigarette. And man when he did that it like,
like a shot off, went in my head. And it was like,
I had never experienced anything like that.
And the money…
- Did you know it was or no?
- That was my first time ever ex- experiencing crack cocaine.
And it blew my mind. Unfortunately,
that started when I was at Ohio State.
- All the money and everything that came
with that Miami trip put you in that situation.
How were you responding to that
over the following years after that?
- This is the thing, I don't know how I
played at such a high, high, high level.
My sophomore year I went on to break all the sophomore records.
Uh, my junior year I went on to break all the junior records.
Every bowl game I played in I was MVP in that bowl game.
And I don't say that from a bragging standpoint,
It’s just, I don't know how I was able to function at that level.
I was always on time, never had any disciplinary stuff.
But ultimately, it's gonna catch up to you.
- Mhmm.
- Yeah. To me, it's not about the money.
I do believe that there's a way that we can compensate,
but giving young people unlimited amounts of income is not the best thing.
I'm not happy for the guys, cuz guys eventually gonna get their money.
I'm more happy for the women.
And they're able to take advantage of it,
- Speak on it, bro.
- TikTok, all these things. Sell them-
Like, yes, they can do it the right way.
- What’s the advice you’d give them right now?
In terms of how to navigate this space
now, being able to monetize all that like…
- I would say that there's really no experts in this area.
And be very careful. The universities can recommend to the athlete
a business or something that they can go to,
but people are gonna make mistakes. This is new
territory, people are going to make mistakes.
But, us thinking that young people are going to be better off
with money than without it, that would be interesting to watch.
- You speak on it first hand.
- Yeah, yeah. Gator.
- [Laughing]
- Yeah.
- So what you got? You got a couple of balls over here tied up.
-  I'm waiting for you to break 'em up down there for me.
- I ain’t got nothing- why, why, why would I do that?
♪♪♪
- Now, Cris Carter scored 1,600 points in high school.
We’re gonna see how nice you still are right
now at basketball. How does that sound?
- Let’s check it out.
- Let’s get the Pop-A-Shot going real quick, alright?
[Digital beeps from game sounding]
I’m gonna start these questions here in 3, 2, 1.
Who was the hardest DB to play against?
- Deion Sanders.
- Best city to visit on the road?
- Green Bay.
- Favorite route to run?
- Ah, I’m nice. Close corner.
- Close corner?
- Yeah.
- Number 80 or number 88?
- 80.
- Who are you listening to before a game?
- Tupac.
- Already. Hall of Fame ring or Super Bowl ring?
- Come on, stop playing. Hall of Fame.
- Funniest teammate you ever had?
- John Randle.
- Slot or wideout?
- Slot.
- Brady or Rogers?
- Brady, man. Stop playing.
- Already. What QB do you wish you could have played with?
- Dan Marino.
- Dirtiest opponent you ever faced?
- Andre Waters.
- Ten seconds-
- Bill Romanowski.
- Bill Romanowski is dirtier.
What current wide receiver belongs in the Hall of Fame?
- DeAndre Hopkins.
- Last one. Best fans in the NFL?
- Any time you go on the east coast, they’re gonna give it to you.
East coast fans.
- What city?
- They rough.
- New York.
- So New York City got the best fans?
- Roughest.
- Roughest place to play, yeah.
- Cris, I appreciate you for coming by the pool hall.
- You got a great show, bro.
- Hey thank you very much, man. Appreciate y’all for watching.